hello everybody out there this is Brock  favors with traffic on the ones  chat off Sean is out sick today so I am  filling in for my usual land reports and  I'm up here at the chopper but I got to  tell you guys I am loving the view all  right well we are we are over the tent  it is massively clogged down there like  a pint of maple syrup on a cool November  morning  [Music]  okay okay I am I am very sorry folks is  a little bit of a bumpy ride up here we  are now approaching the 405 where the  left lane is blocked by a mattress so  somebody is gonna be doing a little  return to Ikea later today  [Music]  right night nobody going down I'm sorry  I'm sorry I'm very sorry folks  I'm very sorry but but I'm losing my  actually you have every right to we're  about to crash  [Music]